community is ambitious our FAQ
are trying to teach better they are
trying to change the world through their
research unlocking the most fundamental
questions of nature the meaning of great
texts and trying to solve the world's
problems the one thing that they don't
want is to face obstacles in their quest
and increasingly IT tools are
fundamental to every aspect of the work
Harvard University we have more than
43,000 employees and we operate a 4.3
billion dollars budget it's an enormous
place where collaboration is critical to
ensuring success for everyone
every day from the ordinary events to
the extraordinary technology is the glue
that brings us together enables Harvard
to share our knowledge with the entire
world
how important is IT to teaching and
research at Harvard it's absolutely
vital all across campus we're thinking
about how to teach better how can we use
the technology to teach better how could
we offer more engaging problem sets or
more engaging material that's really
changing the nature of universities
there are 1,400 members of the IT
community at Harvard all working
together to move the university forward
we helped 40,000 people in the Harvard
community last year we're moving towards
common systems consolidating data
centers and we're moving applications to
the cloud and educating users to be
ancient Egypt is a wonderful graphical
civilization and so the merger of
computers and this ancient civilization
just seems like a given I'm trying to
merge the old and the new or to use the
technologies of the future to study the
past bit by bit
with our new Student Information Systems
that's coming we have the new canvas
rollouts and new tools that are being
developed all the time these are all
ways that we're trying to enhance the
teaching mission make it easier not
harder for the faculty to teach their
classes we have an incredibly diverse
array of students who are obviously all
interested in education but interested
in different aspects of education the IT
staff here are as entrepreneurial as the
students and think about ways to partner
with the students to use technology to
enable the students to achieve the ends
that they want to achieve in every
direction I go the IT staff paves the
way
we're all helping Harvard stay more
secure stronger passwords updated system
secure data it's a massive undertaking
and I'm proud to be a part of it because
we want to move the ideas at Harvard
forward so Harvard University is
expanding its campus to do this we need
miles of new cables
we need Wi-Fi hotspots as you can
imagine technology is the most critical
part of that expansion at Harvard it's
not about any one technology it's about
using the best possible tool to enable
people to learn we need to be at the
cutting edge of IT in order to pursue
our mission effectively today pretty
obvious that technology and education
are going to be linked together for as
far as the eye can see
you